- All right lets close up this hour
with one more story to brighten your day.
This is, What I'm Liking.
(upbeat music)
A Georgia man has collected
tens of thousands of dollars
to help random strangers $1 at a time.
In 2018, he started what
he calls $1 Thursday.
It's a simple social media campaign
in which he asks friends, family,
and neighbors to donate a buck
on any given Thursday to lend a hand
to others who are struggling.
It's had a major impact
on his entire community.
Let's get this do-gooder on the line.
Watching on WSB TV, Atlanta at 10:00 AM,
What's up Anthony?
(audience clapping)
- What's up Kelly, how's it going?
- Oh men its going all
right, well happy Thursday.
- Well thank you and likewise.
- How did all this begin?
- Well, actually in 2018,
I ran into a classmate of mine
and I noticed that she
just didn't look herself.
She gave me a little bit of background
on struggles she's had.
And I couldn't just walk away
and not think about it.
So over in the night,
I heard this voice saying $1, Thursday.
And honestly, it freaked me out,
but I was like, okay, this is God.
I started to type on Facebook, I posted it
basically saying a young lady needs help,
need the community to the rally behind.
Once I posted it, it was
just like, boom she sent $2.
She had no idea this was about her.
And in the midst of receiving that $2,
it turned into one 20 real quick.
I was able to buy groceries,
I was able to give her a $50
for getting her nails done,
even give her a little bit of gas money.
And the warmth that I felt
was just through the roof
like she teared up, she hugged me.
It was a great day.
- Oh my gosh!
It's a beautiful thing to take
care of someone like that.
Thank you so much for sharing
this story with us.
Can you tell us about just
some of the other people
that you may have helped?
- Yes, this time last year, I actually,
we had a gentleman in town
that had a house fire.
He lost his wife and
two kids in this fire.
I saw it via Facebook.
So I pulled $100 out of my pocket
and I was like, you know what,
we gotta get behind them,
we have to do something.
Within 24 hours it raised $8,000.
From there, I went into food systems,
I started to do sneakers for kids
that might need 'em,
or just needed a little pick me up.
Gift baskets for teachers.
And I also had a run in with
the guy who had COVID here in Troup County
he was the first case.
And I was able to bless him with $2,200
when he came home and the community today
literally got behind it and supported it.
- Oh my gosh! You have such a great heart.
Thank you so much for
being such a great example
of how we all should live
our daily lives Anthony.
This is a beautiful
thing that you're doing
for so man people out there.
I'm liking your posts
right now, all right?
- All right, thank you.
- All right, well that's not all.
Our season long partner, Pilot Pen makers
of FriXion the go-to erasable pen
of The Kelly Clarkson Show,
want to celebrate those
creating fearlessly,
just like you.
So they're gonna give you $1000.
How's that sound?
- Gosh, wow! Thank you.
- Yeah, thank you so much Anthony.